[Inaudible].
Yeah. So this is C ballgame, which I have a periodic table here.
It probably be helpful if I point it out to you. It's right down here,
more or less in the middle, but very much towards the bottom.
And this isn't a row of elements that are really quite special because these
guys come after the lanthanides and actinides which these two rows
down here are,
these elements are special because they don't hang around very long.
These elements are actually really unstable and they decay.
This is radio activity at work. So if you want to do anything with these,
you've got to actually make the elements.
You can't just go to a chemical company and buy a job of them.
You've actually got to make them.
And then you've got to turn them into a compound that you're interested in and
analyze it very, very quickly. And some of these elements,
they can come and go within eight, 10, 15 seconds, minutes.
They really don't hang around. You.
You've made them what you want to do with them. Well, the answer could be,
let's make some interesting molecules out of them that we can study and
therefore learn about some of the properties that these elements have,
because at the minute,
because there's so little known about them because a they're very difficult to
make. And even if you do make them, they come and go so quickly.
We don't have expect very much experimental evidence to
help to validate the theoretical models we've got.
The theories are really great, but we need to know that they're accurate.
And so for example,
[inaudible] should be very similar to analogous group six metals.
Higher-up like tungsten, molybdenum, and chromium.
These are very well known, quite well understood elements.
You can make nice stable compounds out of them that will hang around for weeks,
months, and years. And you expect certain periodic trends to occur.
As you go down that group from chromium molybdenum to tungsten.
And the question is what then happens when you go to the really super heavy
Seaborg helium and the next row down.
And so you can predict what you may expect,
but what you need to do is go out and do some experiments to help validate that
theory.
So the news is that a have a search team prepared some Seaborg
Liam, and this is a really elegant reaction. They take some Curium,
which is element number 96,
and they smash some neon into it, which is element number 10.
And that gives you together element 106, which is C ballgame.
Now the clock's ticking because already they're going to start to fall to bits.
And so the answer is, well, the question rather is what are you going to do? Ah,
this particular piece of research is really elegant because what it does is it
generates the sea ballgame atoms,
and very quickly reacts them with carbon monoxide.
And the thing about carbon monoxide is a combined two metal atoms.
In fact, this is one of the reasons why carbon monoxide is not good for humans.
If you inhale it,
it sticks onto the iron in your hemoglobin and stops oxygen being transported
around your body. But in this case,
this has been used to our advantage that you can make a Seaborg helium with
six carbon monoxide bonded to it.
And this is really helpful because now it turns out that this molecule is
volatile. And because it's volatile, you can get it into the gas phase,
quickly weapon off to a detector,
and then confirm that you've made it.
So the reason it's important is it's a volatile compound that you can examine
and you would expect it to be very similar to that. Analogous chromium,
molybdenum, and tungsten carbonyls. And importantly,
they've been known for many decades and we understand their properties very
well. And indeed earlier today, we were just, subliming some,
a group six metal carbon dials,
just to show how they go from being a solid into the gas phase.
And then they come back out again, there's a lovely crystalline solid,
and you would expect the Seaborg Liam Carbonell to be just like this.
The problem is you can't make anywhere near as much of the sea ballgame
Carbondale, and it doesn't hang around long enough to go and put it in a jar.
So the idea behind the project is that you make
the analogous molybdenum and tungsten systems in situ on the same system.
And then when you do it with sea ballgame,
you know what you're looking for and through a very interesting and advanced set
of arrays, it's very elegant work. You can then detect the sea ballgame.
Carbonyl coming out of this system where you've made the atoms of Seaborg Liam
added the carbon monoxide and then fired it down to a detector so that they've
got a bunker of, uh, detectors,
which they have to calibrate. And they do all sorts of control experiments.
Uh,
my understanding is one of the ways they were looking out to make sure they had
the sea ballgame is that C ballgame decays through a certain number of
processes, which I think are fairly well understood.
And you can predict,
and this series of transformations shows up in the detectors and nothing like
that can happen when there's no sea ball game around. So if it does occur,
you know, it has to be down to the sea ballgame.
I can easily understand the reason to create a molecule involving
Seaborg Liam in order to test the theories of what will happen.
Whereas theories correct harder to understand perhaps is why it's
even worth having good, solid theories of what Seaborg and will do,
because seaboard will always be, uh,
something that falls apart and doesn't exist for very long.
So do we need a huge wealth of knowledge about it?
It's not like it's going to help other chemists because no one can work.
With this thing anyway. No, and I disagree with you there. Actually,
I think it does help as chemists because part
actually the theory aspect,
you can't overstate how important that is because we are only as good
as our understanding of the natural world around us.
And that's a bit like saying Mars is a long way away.
And so therefore I don't care what goes on there.
You should care what goes on there,
because it will inform you about the basic principles and the laws that our
universe operates under. And so
when you read the paper about this, Sebald Carbondale,
there's a discussion about how well a carbon monoxide bond to the metal and
will it be stronger or weaker than the analogous chromium,
molybdenum and tungsten systems. Now, this is really important because remember,
I've already said carbon monoxide will bond to iron and poison you.
We need to understand how these types of molecules do interact with these metal
sensors, because this informs our understanding of chemistry and a much broader
context. So although it seems like a really specialist,
very unusual thing that no one would care about.
It's actually got quite profound implications for our broader understanding of
chemistry.
Uh, finally,
I guess finally it got approved in 1997 and it
got approved soon enough.
So seaboard could stand at the periodic table like this
and point to his element.
And we were so happy that he was still alive.
And could point here, this is Seaborg him.